hey did you my burrito oh I don't want
to talk about it why I was hungry I'll
pay you back that's not the point am I
not entitled to nourishment I mean I
didn't deny you shelter before you got
your job I was hungry
yeah now you know how I felt and why did
you roll a sock up in it and put it back
I didn't want you to think like a rodent
had taken it or something that way you
know it was me nope what the hell man
whoa you're eating my pizza why I'm out
getting Froyo how do you see me I set up
a camera mmm
watch this while you're helping Froyo
I'm a student of the human condition go
super Cameron our apartment don't eat my
pizza oh I was totally gonna replace it
with socks multicam system yo I can
still see you oh yeah
what am i doing now jerking off a ghost
screenshotted bye [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you oh my god
I hope bubbles is okay well genetically
speaking pugs are never officially okay
smushed face and all but he kills it on
Instagram - bubbles - bubbles pasta
should be ready any minute
this is Preston my roommate he promised
he was going to stay in his room Preston
hasta LaVista
you don't have to talk to him I'm so
impressed that you cook the last guy I
dated didn't even know how to microwave
anything it's just pasta the sauce is
from a jar at least it's not ketchup
just a second should be just about ready
do you like Parmesan cheese on your
pasta goes great with the sauce
whatever the chef recommends chefs I'm
getting some tonight huh
nothing
what the poor man's Bloody Mary I'll pay
you back I'm sorry we don't have any
butter
it looks good we'll go out next time
pressive what happened that's kind of
sweet texted me that the apartment was
on fire he was trying to surprise you I
guess it is kind of sweet in the most
bizarre way possible you're chairman am
fruit drank Preston's ripe peach on
marshmallows do make a delicious dessert
I have something else at night it's not
a [ __ ]
Oh
you